what is it that you tell your family
slash children about the phenomenon
they find need to find their own answers
we're we're all trying to figure this
out together and it's okay
to to be excited it's okay to be scared
it's okay to be
whatever human emotion you you need to
ascribe to it um
you know it's it's okay there's
i i think
i think honesty and truth is
is the best remedy always
that will get us through pretty much
anything um even even when things are
even when the news is bad even when the
news is good right um
and
i try not to think for anybody don't try
to think for my kids or my spouse or my
friends or you know the only person i
can think for is me
and
you know i tell my kids you know just
be kind to one another be kind to the
world as much as you can you know try to
give back more than you take
um
you know because
i think whether you're talking about
ufos or anything else
that's sound advice if you want to if
you want to
if you want to think about ufos well you
know it depends on on how you lead your
life as a human being
which is going to take you down the road
look there's there's
there's a lot of people out there
that want to hijack the narrative uh but
it's not just because it's a ufo thing
it's because that's the kind of people
they are they will do that with anything
and any opportunity that they're given
ufos is just
one of them but there are people out
there that will try to do that and
hijack that and um
it's uh it's a shame but you know i
i can't change those people i'm not
going to i'm not going to waste my time
changing those people you know they have
to deal they have to deal with that on
their own terms
and that's on them look there's bad
people i face them in washington i face
them on the battlefield you know i face
them in
every day you know when you when you
when someone is trying to to to mug you
or carjack you or something like that
there's just bad people out there
um
you know
so anyways that's that's my
that's my two cents maybe three cents